la semaine dernière lorsque je suis
entré en plateau j'avais raconter une
petite anecdote qui s'était passé en
coulisses oui alors pour ceux qui
n'étaient pas là je propose rapidement
de la regarder et ensuite on en voit le
mas des grands plaisirs bouquet qui
prend un petit dossier en coulisses je
peux commencer par ça si vous voulez ça
les hits anecdote c'est un dossier sur
vous et cyril ans pareil vidéo cette
vidéo a fait il ya un instant recevait
théo m chipolatas y voit un beau
postérieur d'auto il dit mais mais mais
mais tu es un très beau cul sec 6 à 7 et
isabelle mais en fait c'était théo le
lavabo
voilà donc j'ai dit que j'avais pas la
vidéo ouais mais je vous ai menti
thierry lannon cisaille plus vous la
procurer
je suis l'indiquent lundi qu à des
alliés partout dans les coulisses et
j'ai récupéré les images
cyril vous êtes un petit coquinou
[Musique]
je vous ai dit la vérité je vous l'avais
dit avant j'avais dit aux
téléspectateurs puissent condamner la
série le tout à l'heure ah oui oui et
oui mais d'abord je m'intéressais à rené
allait également la semaine prenez vous
allez voir on a une surprise pour lui
incroyable dans un instant que des
pouvoirs fergani aux téléspectateurs un
cadeau incroyable et vous allez avoir
une surprise de ouf
vous allez adorer
vous avez vous allez voir je peux pas
vous en dire plus mais c'est la grande
race sera ce soir en live
je pense que vous allez beaucoup rire
chez vous nous prenez la semaine
dernière j'ai montré que c'était un
homme à femmes c'est vrai qu' il lui
faut tout couronné il lui faut des
chroniqueuses il faut les invités même
on a vu cette semaine dont tu prends pas
ce qu'il lui fallait les dames dans le
public
bref il faut toutes les filles pour rené
il est connu rené je vais vous dire
quelque chose devant toute la france
pas touche à isabelle touché isabelle
isabelle c'est notre mamie par isabelle
c'est notre maman isabelle c'est notre
tata bref c'est toute la famille
isabelle on a besoin d'elle on peut pas
la traiter comme vous le faite que
j'avais récidivé avec une nouvelle
personne j'avais trail isabelle pas
possible
[Rires]
j'ai un beau gosse aux allures mais mon
père chine
je veux bien
[Musique]
regarde moi cette candide qui détendent
brownie tout ça parce qu'elle a des
grosses miches salt choix c'est une
nouvelle bonne humeur est bonne mais
j'ai une vie de yannick et si je suis
tôt durant pudding la petite question
qui est votre chroniqueuse préféré à ben
arous et si la belgique et nick panique
le futur il n'a d'yeux que pour isabelle
et pour sa femme elisabeth c'est de
l'amitié bien entendu ce héros pas vous
cherchiez un billet sur ma bien sûr mais
isabelle fait plus tonique avec lui et
avec tiffany s'est offert vu le plateau
d'autres autre chose on est serrés
autour de cette table
vous avez un très grand chroniqueur qui
était un très grand animateur masse et
benjamin castaldi c'est benjamin
castaldi
mais ce que vous ne saviez pas c'est que
tu sais que c'est toujours un grand
animateur un très grand tu mourir on le
retrouvera d'ailleurs demain benjamin il
fera avant vous oui ils seront ensuite
avec moi dans tpm peu normal puisque je
serai avec vous demain à 19h dans tpm
payer un marché réservé pas là et en
plus voilà et benjamin ça on va quitter
en direct oui moi j'ai plaisir mais on
connaît donc benjamin chroniqueurs on
connaît benjamin animateurs mais est-ce
que vous connaissiez le benjamin
humoriste je connais tous les instants
et fait rire que lui
regardez bien le magnéto qui va suivre
ben jama c'est à chaque fois il lance
claude van mais sauf que le problème bas
c'est que c'est pas encore c'est pas
tout à fait ça n'est pas dans la grosse
rigolade
[Musique]
évident qu'ils envient que donald
renault gagne sont trompés vous savez la
houppette énormément c'est dans les
cours de sport et plus particulièrement
les cours de yoga c'est une posture
favorise l'ouverture jus du corps et
donc nous donnons du temps les cours de
gaza dans un grand silence
on entend par ci par là bd mais moi j'ai
habité et la bougie quelques mises à mal
si la bougie n'a pas comparu
[Musique]
ça
on va des fous et d'autres choses
louis jean michel on sait que parfois il
peut être un peu lourd mais cette
semaine il a battu tous les records
cette semaine à l'échelle il est rentré
en finale de la ligue des champions de
la lourdeur on va pas se mentir c'était
une phrase une lourde moi j'ai fait
comme quelqu'un raout comme dot 9 en
moyenne ce genre de trucs
hubert faut que tu arrêtes le pastis un
jour il arrive encore sûr il y avait
bandé raconte revenir si on écoute pour
vous mais pour le foot non bons gagnent
un match de foot
un collier de l'exporter c'est quand
même style se pose sur tes coups tu te
rends compte que la violence dans un
instant les chroniqueurs vont suivre
vont avoir leurs plus grands draps sera
en live mais je suis obligé de défendre
mes petits camarades est sûr de repartir
mais vous êtes lundi pouvait tout dire
alors je n'ai vu si votre salaire peu
baissé à paraître ce parce qu'on va
approcher de zéro c'est que chaque
semaine on le sait chaque jour même vous
êtes très sympa avec les chroniqueurs en
fait pas tout jeter regardez ces deux
retours ça va alors comment ils vont
tout cela
tous ces petits candidats jettent bourg
vous êtes beau c'est beau
mieux par contre par contre par contre
le côté sarthois
je me suis retourné mais voilà bah oui
avec tes gay pride montpetit qu'elle
serait là il ya 3 me vois ce soir soir
les trois sont vraiment une famille
le vanni kelly tu vois c'est bien mais
réalisable pour m'étais bien vos petites
pancartes et des métiers vous pas
d'enrichir les mettais pas d'autre issue
mais mettez pas dans votre merci les
mettez pas dans votre jeu la question se
pose de savoir et mettez pas dans votre
qi merci les mettais pas dans l'habitude
ne mettez pas dans votre cul mercy
n'était pas dans votre chien pisteur qui
explique que le valais mettez pas dans
le cube merci et puis allez dans un slip
qui rouvre le 25
alors vas tu
[Rires]
joël bats